les armes les uniformes au premier coup
d'oeil on pourrait croire que des
soldats américains sont toujours à
l'aéroport de kaboul et ce sont plutôt
les forces d'élite des talibans venus
faire le tour du propriétaire
au premier jour sans aucune force
étrangère en vingt ans en afghanistan
leur butin de guerre lendemain des
appareils et des véhicules démilitarisé
par les américains en retraite la
victoire est totale et celle de tous les
afghans se réjouissent les talibans elle
doit servir de leçon moubarak pas garde
nous avons un message pour tout
envahisseur éventuel dit il quiconque se
tourner vers l'afghanistan avec de
mauvaises intentions sera confronté à ce
que les états unis ont connu aujourd'hui
aux commandes les talibans doivent
maintenant tenter de relancer les
activités commerciales de l'aéroport de
kaboul laissé dans un état lamentable
eux qui n'ont toujours pas annoncé la
formation d'un gouvernement
les talibans ont donné leur assurance
que les afghans qui souhaite toujours
quitter pays pourront le faire s'ils ont
un visa valide pour l'étranger mais
beaucoup ne veulent pas attendre de voir
s'ils tiendront parole c'est le cas de
besmi la cabane il a préféré braver les
contrôles des talibans sur la route de
kaboul vers kandahar pour ensuite
rejoindre la frontière du pakistan
livre de florence
pour traverser la frontière avec sa
femme et ses quatre enfants une
frontière qui reste officiellement fermé
aux réfugiés afghans bismillah dû payer
des passeurs l'ironie n'échappe pas à
cet ancien commandant de la division des
enquêtes criminelles de la police
afghane il connaissait celui qu'il a
payé le pas s'arrêter sur la liste des
gens qu'il devait arrêter bat lindstrom
a une idée celle alpes et ford aim to
send my touch
tous
ces dernières semaines bismillah n'a
plus que des raisons d'avoir le coeur en
miettes et like a bird now
la
france
erding hoarau
tout ce qui lui reste c'est la certitude
qu'il serait mort à kaboul non seulement
à cause des centaines de talibans qui
l'a envoyé en prison depuis vingt ans
mais parce qu'il est de la minorité
hazara et de confession chiite
lui qui comptait briguer la présidence
de son pays un jour ils se retrouvent
devant rien non
flo
il espère maintenant rebâtir sa vie
ailleurs mais celui-là multiplient les
appels à l'australie à la grande
bretagne et au canada il rêve de pouvoir
y faire le deuil de ce qu'il laisse
derrière
en afghanistan ce sont les pays de
l'otan que les talibans ont enterré
symboliquement dans cette cérémonie
funéraire mais pour autant qu'ils
célèbrent la victoire ils ne sont pas
prêts à couper les ponts complètement
l'émirat qu'il revendique et ce même
afghanistan qui souffre d'une crise
alimentaire aiguë d'une crise financière
profonde et d'une crise sanitaire
alarmante sans l'aide financière de
l'étranger ce sont les afghans qui sont
ensevelis
avoir des relations diplomatiques solide
avec tous y compris les états unis dit
il nous voulons rétablir progressivement
de bonnes relations avec les états unis
à l'avenir et pour rétablir sepang
première étape pour les talibans sa
demeure de rapidement démontré qu'ils
peuvent et qu'ils vont former un
gouvernement qui sera non seulement
accepté par une majorité d'afghans mais
qui pourra être un interlocuteur pour la
communauté internationale et pour toutes
ses promesses d'un règne plus modéré
plus respectueux du droit des afghans et
des afghanes il leur faut en faire la
preuve les échos des arrestations
ciblées des exécutions sommaires et de
la disparition rapide des femmes de la
sphère publique sont loin d'être
encourageants et si marie ève bédard
radio-canada islamabad